welcome to this video a 15 minute game
against white squared form let's see
sorry with an English English opening
young very flexible central plain white
might play d4 black might play deform
you can prepare it you can just feel and
Chet oh let's see what happens
John
yeah I actually like d5 but he didn't go
for that I can also start with you for
you know what I want to do is I want to
get the maroc see point with e for and
deform probably will take it's not
advisable to let why take on c5 I guess
hmm that's quite curious not taking here
on d4 immediately
yeah somewhat strange to think about
that for so long as you really cannot do
my Jones no we you know it's playing
quickly we we get the accelerated dragon
peroxy bind again as often mentioned the
structure that I really like to play
with white i also have a fair share of
experience from the black side but at
some point i decided to give that up
because it simply didn't feel right for
my style of play don't like to can seat
so much space in the center quickly it
is not a terribly bad opening but you
need to be very patient with black and
now I didn't like it yeah that's it's
interesting quickly Bishop to e6
and yeah what can take on e6 and damage
the pawn structure I was I'm only
thinking briefly if this is really so
promising yeah I guess I really should
do that but so sometimes white needs to
be a bit bit cautious with them
transformation than the center's white
has a weakness and this is the defrost
Graham set up like a 594 is always
always something to consider but here it
feels like the light squares on the
blacks with e 6 cm feels really weak so
I guess I should occupy the center maybe
later thinking about just attacking of
the pawn with Bishop g4 or maybe c5 this
is also an interesting way to play
yeah I'm not sure what black should do I
mean there is even here maybe you should
consider to play e6 to e5 trying to get
a piece to reform I don't really see
much much else in terms of let's say for
wordplay you can just employ a sit and
wait strategy Queen d7 King edge a rook
CAE to something like that basically
doing nothing and awaiting a
developments yeah but it's nots not a
very attractive prospect maybe five
after that I'm not sure lettuce I didn't
really think of yeah I have G form now
come on let's do that I know very
quickly played i usually don't think so
long about it but I had had thought
about the idea g4 anyway g4 g5 Bishop g4
and Bishop age six is just so inviting
this move it's non-threatening g5 with
the winner of a piece he almost is
obliged now to move the the night or the
bishop and lose even more time after g5
at Bishop g4 so while this is why i
played this so quickly
ok so the immediate g5 and Bishop g4
well I guess so the only issue is Bishop
takes c3 em but this is not really a
problem no it isn't him this would
actually help me because D for is
covered and he has a hard time to cover
a six cm
yeah okay hmm
hmm interesting I can try I can play a 5
immediately I can play Bishop e6 first
and then f5 now probably I'm not so sure
it looks at first sight it looks
overwhelming but this always this 94
counter play and if the bishop is only
six um the door is has this black always
has this capture so I'm may be in fact
f5 is the it's the better move I'm tough
tough I think f5 is better really the
bishop only six can be easily can easily
turn out to be a liability would have
played Bishop b6f five they would they
always was a bishop d5 I forgot about
that that there is a square on d5 maybe
then there should be six check was most
may be preferable yeah well white is
fine here I'm not complaining but yeah
this was probably then better if I
simply didn't think about the square d 5
okay well black IAM probably just has to
play 90 form maybe 95 it's the only
alternative that i can think of
yeah of course if you place 94 I will
only take it on deform if I'm winning
instantly with the technical with some
technical means other than that the
knight on d4 is a piece that I can never
take us after he takes you for the 97
and the bishop on g7 suddenly get alive
and yeah I really don't see anything
else he can play 95 but besides some
covering these six square the smooth
it's not doing doing much yeah what's my
idea I mean if I have lots of time on my
hands I'll play rook at 3h three Queenie
one Queen EdgeWalk green h7 made but
that's very long this plan and if he
goes to d4 with the night Rugare 383 is
tough to play this is one reason why i
thought that 94 is also just a good idea
um yeah what what what is my play
against 94-95 could be a possibility
trying to provoke the exchange yeah that
took it took him a while but then he
played the the move yeah what I wonder
is if I have a direct technical IDM with
the table spoons capturing here actually
but a kanji 6f takes bishop d for ED
Bishop e6 check king age seven Queen g4
then after any Queen h4 made winning
isn't this very very dangerous it does
look very dangerous really the only
problem is if it is not working and I'm
misjudging things then I have spoiled
all my advantage taking on d4 and g6r to
a strategically totally undesirable
moves the only reason to play them is
okay they win
if they don't win it's it's really
useless but I don't I really don't see
an antidote come on let's not be afraid
of ghosts have a think it should it
should just win
ok now the caption on deform it takes an
f1 queen everyone ed for Bishop you six
checkers is really directly winning and
here ed Bishop be sick shocking agenda
screen G for h1 yeah I really don't see
a defense very important is that there
is this pawn on d5 that always that
always keeps age six under control
so go into g4 probably maybe black can
take on f1 and play Knight f82 to avoid
the immediate made look everyone look
everyone look at night f8 check on edge
or night h7 hmm maybe that's not an
immediate made but there really should
be something just one look this one ok I
can play it first and think later
tonight f ADM cannot take it ok on this
check on each Friday on suspicion page
six
native 8
hmm FF other ideas that probably
probably word his side but I'm thinking
about about some concrete measures like
a queen edge for night of Adia Queen
edge for check night h7 and then 95 to
f4 takes on g6 so this this could be an
idea however
I have I have another idea that actually
pretty strong i think i can give the
check HERE jak nie Dage seven and now
look F for 2h form Brooke f4d takes you
three look H form can only give one
check on b6 then King everyone and Luke
age seven meters is deadly really yeah I
think that's it I think that's it Queen
85 maybe maybe Queen a five loops with
g5 being attacked
Wow Queen f5 the bad thing is on a move
on Queen 85 if i play 95 the squeaky one
check that's not really great
maybe I can yeah this was really not
good what I did Queen a five now I need
to worry about this and they were very
they were quite a number of easy ways to
do it like 95 for example and said i
will get form just playing in a simple
fashion maybe queen a five I can play
nine to Bishop g5 yeah well I actually
thought that you care for is the simple
fashion it isn't what what do I play
after Queen to a 5k
okay so i can hear there's a thought to
some relatively simple it's it's a bit
it's a bit too much material take here
okay Brooke age seven takes on c3 takes
on g7 Queen c3 is simple look at seven
Bishop g4 check kingi to takes on b2 and
rook takes is seven was made to come
okay check
yeah if it takes rook e7 and then there
is Queen age 72 f seven mate this cannot
be prevented Bishop g7 I just take it at
Quincy three getting the pawn check now
you should resemble should have played
Queen 85 I'm I wasn't totally sure how
to win then can go back to the spot
attune to see what the engine is saying
okay this is winning F text you 60 this
assessment was correct be sure before I
am ok there is there is no real defense
Queen g-form Jack this is the checklist
and okay here the computer wants to
improve it plays this this and rook f3
intending tending this okay yeah I
understand this is a very similar idea
but the main difference is that g4 is
not hanging so this move is just no use
at all as check of course he has a pin
on the on the on the night okay yeah but
I hope that my line is also winning
Queen a5 it seems so it seems to be
winning still but this is much stronger
with this with this idea yeah okay but i
really had overlooked Queen a five year
I just thought he has no move I only saw
exactly the line in the game yeah but
really queenie queenie five this is
tricky now
I Bishop b5 is the best I would have
played that i'm pretty sure i don't i
don't really have something else I mean
the CM jack is probably even good for
black so what is there I cannot go here
check this is at least a draw check and
you can probably lose if you play some
nonsense okay so Queen a five Bishop g5
is right and now I keep this alive if it
takes okay choice again a win so what
should like do maybe I'm can we cards
the moves like that Bishop takes check
that's not good if I take with the Queen
you can take here there is no immediate
made on the edge farm so this is the
right move 85 problem jack takes here
yeah that will be I need to do this just
play with tempo all the time check but
whatever winning hmm I'm not sure check
check even here I mean the problem is I
cannot take here because this is again a
draw but okay I have this chest probably
it's still winning somehow but hmm it
wasn't it wasn't necessary at all
obviously I should have just should have
just played played 95 here instead of
from check I mean or queen edge form and
check once here I really should do this
and oops and that's easy with those
totally am paralyzed pieces why the tech
wolf will break through red to freeze
and
okay i hope you enjoyed the game thanks
for watching